thank you very much nice to be here i
was uh i was exercising today and there
was a man
on the machine next to me
listening to a discman
today
today this happened today i did i didn't
recognize it initially they're much
bigger than you remember much
much bigger i i thought he was listening
to a pizza
huge
huge and then don't get me wrong i i had
a disc man this is how long ago i got my
disc man i paid 188 dollars
for my disc man 188 i could go over to
rite aid right now with 188 dollars and
bring back a discman for everyone in
this room
in fact if you'll go ahead and reach
under your seats
for 188 dollars though it came loaded
load all the best features all the bass
boost you betcha
you you bet it had bass boost if at any
time you thought to yourself is that all
the bass
boost oh oh false alarm everyone fought
plenty more bass where that bass came
from
had uh anti-shock
anti-shot indispensable get the
anti-shock because if if you were strong
enough to jog while carrying this
manhole cover this this olympic discus
then then the disc would not skip for
the minute the batteries lasted while in
anti-shock mode it was
pivotal
this is the sweetest feature on the disc
ban though the must get beg borrow and
steal my friends but get the shuffle
get the shuffle you do not know what in
the sam hill is coming up next
when you hit shuffle on a disc every
time a song ends cliffhanger clip oh
oh which one of these songs is going to
pop up next
which one of these 10
songs
[Music]
if it's rocketman again i will lose
my ma
and it's rocketman oh my lord what are
the chances what are the
chances
ten
percent i shouldn't make fun of the guy
he's just trying to make ends meet the
economy is bad there sometimes i go to
the mall i can't believe certain
businesses are still
open
best example things remembered
how how do they stay profitable i
they they'll etch your initials in an 80
letter opener
i don't know about you guys but the
first thing i cut into when times got
tough
engraving
my engraving budget is a skeleton of
what it was last year yes last year we
were all
loosey-goosey we were engraving
everything
we could drag into things remembered but
now when i wake up in the morning and i
and i go over my two engrave list i say
gary do you have to engrave this today
today
does this does this money clip
with three ones and a bus pass does it
need
a monogramming today no put it off
discipline
i'll tell you who's doing well though
the a with the circle around it
the at sign the abbreviation for at it's
on twitter separating it's on the your
email address
and uh when i was a kid the only time
you saw it was when charlie brown swore
lucy would pull away the football and he
would let loose with a vulgar string of
pound signs asterisks and add signs that
would make a hooker blush it was
rippled and now it's everywhere it's the
abbreviation for act
we're shortening two-letter words
who is that lazy off i have to cross one
more damn t
it's sucking the life out of me
i love
crossing a tee
i love it's so empowering
and and
confession time
when i was a kid i wanted my
parents to change my name to scott
because there are two t's at the end of
a properly
and by cursive law if you have two t's
in a row you get to sign them both with
a flourish it's not uh
it's
and that's why scots are always very
well-adjusted confident men because
since they're little kids they get to
sign their name like their baseball star
i'm scott i'm scott who are you i'm
scott i'm six years old and i'm zoro i'm
scott
thank you very much everyone